The Golden Ticket is what I'm announcing.
That's right, like a good neighbor of
my friends at State Farm are
helping me give a select few
the chance to virtually meet me,
Sona, and of course Gourley,
but I want to just really emphasize me.
Oh come on.
You're gonna meet me
and Sona and Gourley
and maybe even be featured right here
on Conan O'Brien Needs
a Friend, all right.
Here's how it works,
we're gonna be releasing
these golden tickets
on Team Coco's Instagram, on TBS
and of course, right here on my podcast,
you never know where these
golden tickets are gonna be,
where they're going to show up.
So you have to pay attention,
then when you see one
you have to act quick
or is it act quickly.
I think it's act quickly,
isn't it an adverb?
That's what I think,
it says right here, act quick.
Someone screwed up.
Exactly, anyway so you just might be
one of the lucky few, all right.
Head to TeamCoco.com/GoldenTicket
for more details.